in 2013 Soto was working on an  experiment on antimatter  the group assembled a hybrid antimatter  matter atoms by firing the anti-protons  into liquid helium they're rather than  annihilating each other they instead saw  the helium becoming more ordered less  collisionally broad on spectral lines  and this became more well-behaved if you  will the small cohort of anti-protonic  helium atoms cool sounding name for a  fascinating type of new material but how  could it be wouldn't the protons  eventually suck in the antiprotons how  could you get them to capture each other  this could not be explained immediately  why the helium was so well behaved okay  it was obvious that something was  preventing the helium atoms from  imploding on each other but what could  that be so the researchers had to  explain and